I think people should be wearing suits
all the time I think anytime you want to
portray the best version of yourself a
suit is a great uniform to reach for but
I look at pictures of like my dad 2530
years ago if he's in a good fitting suit
he still looks relevant today if I would
look at photos of me 25 years from now I
would hope that what I'm wearing still
looks relevant then design can be a
really chaotic process there's a certain
beauty in that chaos in fact there's so
many possibilities when I'm designing a
garment for client I am spending a lot
of time going over the buttons and the
linings and the thread colors the
quality of every lining or every fabric
matters if I consider myself a master
than anything it's really being a master
of conveying I think my point of view
and sharing my influences and taste
level and a concise message in manner
and I have a lot of fun doing it people
have consistently said I completely get
what you're trying to do like it comes
through in every image that I see you
put out there comes through in the
videos that you make it comes through in
the words that you write and connect
write your story in I take a lot of
pride in that
you